foreign
comic book movies was a place that fox
could separate themselves from the rest
of the movies that were being made out
there Bez full CG yes doing those kinds
of shots you have to
fight
you were working on this movie Behind
the Scenes as a producer right executive
producer and
uh what was that like
thanks to huel for sponsoring this video
stick around to find out more about it
hey everybody welcome back to a very
exciting episode of visual effects
artist react we're here that was
exciting yeah
[Laughter]
we're here with the amazing director Tim
Miller Tim you founded this tiny little
Indie studio called blur you also did
this little like startup movie called
Deadpool you did like a Terminator thing
like small stuff right just nerd wet
dream stuff that's where I specialize in
hey real quick I would feel bad if I
didn't mention at the beginning of this
episode that we have an hour-long
version of this on Corridor digital.com
we were completely blown away with how
open Tim was with sharing stories from
the industry so if you want to see that
magic preserved head on over to Corridor
digital.com to check out the hour-long
version of this episode there's a little
movie trailer that dropped about three
and a half years ago for Sonic the
Hedgehog uh meow yes and the internet
kind of got angry about it
you are working on this movie Behind the
Scenes as a producer right executive
producer and
uh what was that like
because I will say the very very first
episode of vfxrs react we looked at this
trailer did you pile on like yeah
that's disgusting we're trying to
highlight all the things that you have
to get right to make a CG shot work
everything from making it feel like it
passed the camera making it feel like a
pass to the lens even with the physics
dealing with the reality of it dealing
with art Direction but the real thing is
the design Jeff is an animator and I
hired him right out of college so he was
at blur for I don't know 15 years and
he's a character anime that's his first
and foremost thing when he attacked the
design problem he's thinking of it as an
animator he's thinking I gotta have a
character who can look like he got a
pair of shoes from a kid's bedroom I
have to have hands that can open up
doors and pick up human objects a
character with no teeth is a problem for
animators and those eyes are in the
default design they're not anything that
approaches real yeah like a full white
Shield yeah exactly it was really hard
on the other hand you have a brand
everybody knows and everybody loves the
look of this character but he's got to
fit into this real world and there's a
lot of examples where there is a
translation of that so he does it and of
course Mayhem ensued so then I go over
to to Jeff and I said here's what you
need to do you need to go out and you
need to say I [ __ ] up to the fans you
need to say Mia culpa I hear you we will
fix this and Jeff said already did it he
didn't wait for the corporate machine to
get around to putting out a message
which I feel like would have been the
totally wrong thing to do he just did it
it was the smartest thing he could have
possibly done I know it's goofy to say
this but I was very proud of him
so you're saying is that the conspiracy
theory this is a very Advanced marketing
move where you guys secretly had this
Sonic design if you release the trailer
with the other Sonic design just to get
everybody talking no but but in
hindsight and Jeff and I have talked
about it in hindsight I feel like it was
the luckiest horrible thing that could
happen because I feel like the fans
appreciate the fact that their voice was
heard and it made them feel some sense
of ownership in the success of the movie
and they should feel ownership the final
character design
faithful but looked great too like you
guys did a great job of like preserving
the cartoonish nature of something while
still like implementing it into reality
you know it all worked out in the end
wait
you may be wondering why the red suit
well that's so bad guys can't see me
bleed several years ago this movie
called Deadpool game yeah whose balls
did I have to fondle to get my very own
movie so how much do you want to talk
about how this movie ended up getting
made there's no easy way to say this
I'm pregnant Trevor this is the original
test clip the idea was I'm gonna use all
CG sequences to make it feel big in
scope even though it was low in budget
and I didn't have time or the knowledge
to go out and shoot this so we did an
all CG test as a proof of concept which
I was
super happy with how it turned out
and he recognized all the guys in that
car that's Darren Ross animation
supervisor at blur but yeah a stunt
coordinator Dan Ross is in a lot of our
cinematics because he was the only head
we had scanned for a while
I feel like it was really important that
you guys hit a Vibe Like A vibe that's
like still fun and playful but very much
not the Marvel Cinematic Universe while
being in that Superhero universe and
that little test short you guys
definitely hit it in my opinion we did
this test did a budget put a plan
together and fox said we don't believe
in the movie and then the test leaked
but it was a beautiful thing that
happened for all the right reasons but
it wasn't me it was one of those things
that I think should remain secret
because a mystery is more interesting
than the truth the leak is what got the
entire like audience excited about this
because they're like oh wait a minute
this is dope like I want to see a full
feature length of this and that got so
loud to the point that like the studios
just couldn't ignore it anymore correct
well a whole series of events kind of
happened at one time Emma Watts realized
that R-rated comic book movies was a
place that fox could separate themselves
from the rest of the movies that were
being made out there it was a business
opportunity they could own that segment
of the market then also Simon kimberg
came on who is the gatekeeper of the
Marvel stuff at Fox do I believe that I
would have directed it
maybe not you know maybe they would have
said oh you know what I think this is a
real movie let's get uh Robert Rodriguez
to come in and direct it who had been
attached to it before and you know
Hollywood is not a fan of giving
first-time directors a shot with no
experience it just so happens that I got
lucky is the mask
as you can imagine there was a lot of
discussion about the costume and I
really believe it's got to be the comic
book costume and you can see we had the
costume design right from this test at
the beginning and Ryan saw the costume
before it was aged down he had a moment
where he was like dude Ah that's gonna
look terrible I can't that's gonna look
awful and I'm like just hold on when we
age it down it's going to look awesome
and then the joy when he put that
costume on the first time was palpable
like you like you saw me a minute and
you just knew we had a muscle suit
undershirt under that we took it out it
didn't need it he just looked great and
I always see Deadpool as kind of slim
anyway he's live He's live yeah he has
to be fast let's count him down
this was a tricky sequence to shoot
because we could only shut the highway
down for a certain amount of hours in
the day the whole sequence takes place
over like what five minutes but you're
trying to match lighting over a period
from like 8 A.M to 3 P.M usually you're
using live action shots to tie into
bigger all CG sequences here we're
almost using the CG shots to tie into
different lighting scenarios across the
setting and then we ended up doing a lot
of background replacement too yeah
because I remember seeing a breakdown so
much of everything beyond that bridge
there I remember seeing like oh that was
rendered I didn't even realize yeah we
wanted to make it feel like it was a big
city Vancouver doesn't have tons of
super tall buildings and you know Roto
has helped enormously by a guy there's
no hair yeah yeah and most of those
shots give it up for Chastity I forgot
Stanley was in this I had a whole bunch
of jokes for what he says so Stan was
sitting he's like oh I can't say that
okay can't say that oh no there's no way
I'm saying that I can't say that the
worst day on this was the strip club we
were like two hours behind and then we
went out in the alley to shoot the stuff
that was in the Rain the producers like
you've got 30 minutes to shoot just oh
my God sequence
I said we're gonna have to come back
because we get there's no way we got
stunts and there's wire pulls and Rigs
and he's like uh we can't come back here
this is like this is this is the most
expensive day so that's where I feel
like I earned my money as a director
because I go okay scrap the plan Ed
you're just going to walk out of the
Shadows you're gonna frighten her Gina
you're going to step out and she's going
to close the line you take her down and
that's it we had a whole fight sequence
where Vanessa she gets slammed against
the wall and she has a taser and she
tases angel dust in the side of the neck
and you know we show some fight I mean
that's a high pressure moment to be like
all right everything's here all the
resources are set up my entire plan gone
make something up now this is stupid to
say but I gotta admit I kind of like
those those moments me too because you
feel like oh this is my kids can be a
hero yeah and this is my chance to show
my medal the articulating eyes I had
never seen that before Deadpool was this
the first one to do that I don't know if
it's been done somewhere else if it did
it's subconscious I don't I don't
remember there's a funny story with the
eyes there because we had them in our
effects budget and we were over budget
and so I cut the mask animation and I
cut the frozen moment opening sequence
and the rationale was if it's a great
movie I'll get the money to do it and if
it's not a great movie this is not going
to save it
and so and so I cut them and then of
course you know we had a pre-vis of the
Frozen moment which was awesome and so
we got to put it back and we did some
tests with the masks and you you kind of
see how much it helped and then we did
it summer comp tricks summer CG head
replacement some are just pulling
splines and it helps a ton oh
I'm touching myself tonight that was one
of the five jokes that the old Fox
regime said well this is not funny and
it must be removed from the script and
when it brought the house down at
Comic-Con
I was like yes I told you if you like
this episode we have one more coming out
with Tim Murray Deep dive into game
cinematics as well as love death and
robots with the Show creator himself so
subscribe to not miss it what's your
favorite action film of all time Aliens
yeah yeah so your favorite action film
of all time directed by James Cameron
and now you're working on a film with
Jim Cameron that future never happened
cause I stopped it these are CG faces
aren't they yeah these are that's
incredible that's a stunt double
originally the sequence had a lot of
dialogue between John and Sarah that
wasn't plot based it was just the mother
and son talking and it just we never
even got halfway across the uncanny
valley the minute you start hand
tweaking the keyframes for lip shapes
your
and so I knew they weren't going to get
there so Julian and I cut a version
without the dialogue which you know what
I was quite happy with we didn't need
the dialogue that was there before you
know another thing I'm just realizing is
I think what helps the scene is it's all
in slow-mo it means we can't really rely
on like the motion to inform us whether
something's real and we're just looking
at the visuals and the visuals in my
opinion are very good in this scene it
definitely helps to do it in slow-mo you
sidestep some of the stuff that normally
catches you out I know it seems goofy
now but at some point they were having
such trouble with John I said I've read
about this new technology called Deep
faith can we do some deep fakes of John
and just project it on the face and ilm
tried it and even though it didn't work
for the final it did inform the
animators a little bit Ah interesting
using using a deep fake as reference for
the actual renders and animations
exactly
there's that shot where he gets hit in
the back of the head I kept hearing like
Jim hates the shot Jim hates the shot
I'm like why I think he's going to be a
cool shot and it was because of the
visual effects of the goo wrapping
around the hammer weren't in there and
in my mind that was always the plan but
Jim didn't know what the plan was so he
so he hated the shot because it looked
fake and then as soon as that got in
there he was like oh great shot using
your CG goggles with the right context
you forget that everybody is not seeing
the same movie that you are inside your
forehead this shot's super cool dude
that's so cool
that was actually one of the scenes we
have looked at from this movie before
all that animation is terrible yeah we
could use the animation we're like
statistics don't look real here oh my
God
is that his motion is too linear and it
doesn't really represent like the
Gravity Force pressing back on me kind
of just like jumps and is very just as
opposed
some shots you just run out of time you
get locked into the plate timing of the
camera move or whatever and you don't
have as much control as if it was an all
digital shot so I'm setting for a shot
like that it's a camera guy just taking
the camera like all right I think it's
like a loop Boop okay I'll just I'll
just boop boop and then I'll just get a
shot and then just like yeah roll the
dice and like later on you're like oh
dang this was shot at this car factory
in Hungary it was taking longer and we
had to go shoot another day so we had to
ask all the workers who ran the machines
we didn't know how to run the machines
and we wanted them moving in the
background so we had to ask them and
they asked them if they would come in on
a Saturday and we'd pay him a lot of
money and they said no oh wow and so I
said let me go talk to him and I grabbed
a camera pad from the cameraman and I
went into their break room and I put it
down on the floor and I got on my knees
and I said please please I'm begging you
and somebody's translating for me please
come in I need these shots desperately
I'm begging you please come in and they
said okay
but at first they were like why is this
man and on his knees in front of us so
that's the biggest director
I feel like being a director is getting
a shot I mean there's a line at which my
dignity won't cross but I haven't found
it yet
with this we're transitioning from the
actual location to Stage here and
everything in the background Beyond
maybe 50 feet is digital because
everything is sceniced up for stunts
pads everywhere you got to be able to
rig for wires to do stuff like that
whoa wait this is one of my favorite
shots that's full CG yes we do a
transition right there as a transition
wow dang doing those kinds of shots you
have to
fight because that's not an easy shot
it's not a cheap shot yeah that was so
you got you got friends of her on a blue
screen there is that being projected
onto her or like that's full CG so the
it looks so good though they get it for
reference or for just in case I think
the thing that maybe is different with
me than a lot of directors maybe is I'm
just not afraid to do all digital shots
I'm like oh we'll just do it let's do an
lcg shot there no problem because I know
we can and usually I'm right
occasionally I'm wrong
this sequence was one of the biggest
Minds you have gravity from a plane
going down you have the plane is
spinning so you have centrifugal force
and so where is up and where is down is
changing across all the sequences and we
had this amazing full 360 rotating set
um that we built in this giant warehouse
and then they found asbestos in the
warehouse oh no uh right before you
started to shoot so two weeks that I was
supposed to shoot on this rotating set I
had to shoot on a stationary set which
made everything you know doubly harder I
had a great pre-vis of course but I'm
constantly going okay so gravity is this
way and centrifugal forces this way so
put the air blowers over here
I was really happy to see
in the trailer and then we redid it
this is one of my favorite shots coming
up here where you think the thing is on
its back but it gets up it's cool it's
the animation that you've never seen
before it's little moments that you get
to be like oh I get to try this new
thing it's like yeah robots are not
people at the end of the day they can do
impossible things like this like the
timing is just perfect boom
foreign
with her arms the flesh ripping off yeah
with the spider tank scene so sick
on this one we had Arnold on one of
those shake weight machines where it's
like to get this vibration here like one
of those things yeah I'm like let's get
one of those things so he can really
look like he's being I was really happy
with the way those shots shut up right
Arnold was laughing the whole time
okay I have a quick prediction to make
right now at this point you're really
liking this episode and you don't want
to end so remember we have an hour-long
version of this with Tim's full stories
uncut on the website corridorjigital.com
and for the second episode of Tim Miller
coming up that's also going to be an
hour long there's a free trial go check
it out plus a bunch of other crazy stuff
no ads thanks for watching hope you guys
have enjoyed this episode of visual
effects artists react it was brought to
you by our good friends over at huel
when we're in the zone working on son of
a dungeon we've got hundreds of VFX
shots to get through we don't want to
you know be getting out of that flow
state to go cook and use lame pots and
pans
done don't cut the fuel I won't cut the
fuel I don't know how to cook I'm gonna
be honest it's true he's a terrible cook
yeah thanks we want something that's
quick we want something that's going to
get us back on the computer working on
the shots that we want to do that we
want to create who makes that possible
for us if you want to be cool huel is a
tool to fuel good dude
they have strawberry shortcake they have
chocolate vanilla all sorts of other
flavors vanilla's my favorite and it's
done instantly and you can keep working
it's the best thing in the world
oh yeah baby 40 grams of protein in
every serving less than five grams of
sugar it's crazy it provides you with
all the carbohydrates proteins fats
fiber and all 27 essential
micronutrients your body needs to thrive
that's crazy imagine if your carrots and
your broccoli and your peas taste like
strawberry shortcake if you want healthy
convenient plant-based and affordable
food check out Hue feels good to say
feels good to make it louder so much
power in that powder say it louder so
much power in that powder say it louder
oh so much power in that powder
sorry try to keep it cool drink your
fuel don't be a fool so if you guys care
about saving time and money without
sacrificing nutrition check out your
link in the description below it will be
the best decision you've ever made
seriously at least today just I don't
know if legally where it'll be a good
choice no back to react
Tim thank you so much for joining us
today I had a blast chatting with you
hearing your stories about Terminator
Deadpool like all of this stuff that was
so much fun I hate talking I hate
talking about this [ __ ] I'm so tired of
talking about Deadpool and Terminator
and love death now
you're like don't you have other [ __ ] to
do no let's talk some more well it was
an honor having you here thank you so
much oh it's an honor to be here it's
just nerds talking about [ __ ] oh yeah I
could do for hours you know that's why I
started an animation studio so I had
other nerds to talk to thanks for
watching Everybody I'll see you in the
next one